what are some small routines art your
day that you find to be really helpful
or you think people would benefit from
doing them like some people would be
like meditation maybe yeah you're gonna
get with like a bunch of cliches let me
do a get like give them to me yeah
so the at least what I try to do first
thing in the morning is write three
notes of gratitude
so like things that I'm thankful for
that's first thing in the morning where
did you learn that I have no idea it I
think it came I'm sure it came from a
podcast or a video or something I have
no idea the origin but it came from the
Internet is my guess and so I that's
probably the most ingrained routine I
have then after that I would say
exercise is like if I don't go for a run
or I don't do something similar like my
day is not as good as it could have been
that's a big one mm-hmm and again
meditation is awesome I don't I'm not
like as disciplined as some people are
who are like going through a program and
you know getting increasingly making it
harder for themselves as they go I using
the one recording every day mm-hmm it's
a guided meditation right and I really
like it those routines are big and then
there's another one I guess actually
before the gratitude notes is make your
bed big one that comes from
what's-his-name
I can't remember his name right now but
he is a an old navy commander and my
friend had this had his book on his
shelf and I said can I borrow that and
then I read it's like 10 it's basically
ten rules that you should have that he
learned from the Navy SEALs all right
first one being make your bed because
there's so much uncertainty in life that
you need to have you need to start every
day with a small
victory no matter even if it's just
making your bed there needs to be some
stability before the uncertainty of life
kicks in and I think just whether you
think it or not it's helping your brain
in some way get going with the day and
then there are other days where like I
take a shower and I'm like that was the
biggest wind today that's as far as I'm
gonna get I've had the thing but I think
those routines are really big for me I'm
trying to think oh and then the last one
is like everybody should pick up a book
and try to read for at least an hour and
if you came to ours that's what I try to
go for every day it's not always gonna
happen but I have found that it's been
putting aside an hour to two hours a day
for reading instead of an hour to two
hours of flashing screens in front of
your face is is far more beneficial to
your life than anything else it doesn't
have to be you know a productive book
that's teaching you about how to live
better or or some new theory it could be
detective fiction that gets you going
but as long as you're reading for an
hour at least today I think is really
big
[Music]